You can add jQuery to any website using script tags, like so.
You can host this file on your own server with a path like this one,
but it's actually recommended to use a version of jQuery hosted on
a content delivery network or CDN.
CDNs are usually much faster than your own server,
plus it allows you to take advantage of the browser's caching feature.
jQuery and Google both host jQuery.
Given the sheer number of websites using jQuery, you're definitely safe using
either Google or jQuery's official host to host for your production builds.
And don't forget to use the minified version of jQuery in production.
The minified version of jQuery is considerably smaller, so
it's going to lead to faster page loads.